so this is just a quick announcement to  say that my latest video the  interpretation of Logan that we  remastered has been blocked by YouTube  well actually by Fox turns out Fox is  very finicky on their copyright so  that's a little bit annoying I guess it  comes with the territory of doing movie  interpretations so we're gonna try to  figure this out and probably put it back  out again or I'm not sure we'll see we  need to figure out a way for it not to  get blocked again and so sorry about  that if you've been sharing it or if you  haven't watched it yet I'm gonna put  back the older version make it public  again so at least that'll be up but uh  yeah we'll figure it out